I said of this you do man okay where we
are live with another hangout we have
rich who is a toronto in city
photographer videographer who's on a
mission to make the world more inspired
rich it's been a while since our last
session bro it has and has been a while
give us the update the scoop well you
know i don't know where to start there's
lots been going on a lot of a lot of
fireworks in my head have been shooting
a lot of videos as well i updated my
website so I've been working my website
as well to kind of clear up the message
yeah kind of distinction between by my
work which is photography and getting
work mercial work and my mind spire move
it so wait its work in progress it's
almost done the website and I've done of
few interviews I've got a bunch more
videos ready to be released so that's
kind of a short of it now ready video
now to you sent me an exciting email
friend that was pretty exciting what
happened well a good day I mean I'm
ready to do it I'm just kind of helping
myself up a little bit kind of
practicing it but i'll probably have it
recorded within a week reported and
launched within a week this is rich's
first time on camera filming himself oh
yeah the fear overcoming fear it's a
great it's a great series for you man
yeah yeah I think so so what are you
going to do so you sent me that you sent
me that word doc which kind of outlines
everything you're going to say when what
you're gonna you're gonna are you use a
teleprompter you're gonna you're gonna
just gonna fly off the top your head see
what happens what's the plan I don't
know I've been practicing a little bit
trying to figure it out and I have to
figure out the teleprompter there's
something I guess or some kind of
program for that but that I'm just kind
of reading and using my face time and it
doesn't look good being read I'm I
figured I'll practice it a few times see
if I couldn't if I could nail it and in
one shot straight from the heart I think
that would be the best way
do it yeah but it might be a good idea
as a backup how do you do it yeah it's
awesome I mean there there is as easy as
it says if you want to use a
teleprompter it's as easy as getting an
appt their apps that you can get for
your phone that can go through it and
put the phone by the camera but honestly
you lose the heart when you read even if
the words are passionate you lose the
heart and I much rather have you just
try to get it out and take as many texts
you need to and it's not going to be
perfect like you'll miss some points
gonna happen you'll miss the point it
won't be one hundred percent but if it's
a trade-off and the passion is way more
important than the exact words John turn
um what I do now is before so so I'm
making a video somebody's asking me a
question I'm going to do response what
I'll do is I'll think about what I want
to say like 'how would answer this
question and I'll pace a little bit in
around the room and I'll pace i'll be
like a mutter to myself you know then
you know sorry start working on that a
little bit and then and then i'll just
get in front of the camera and let it
come out and it's never exactly as I
practice but it's it's with a lot of
intensity and passion typically and it
does well so I know your thing was long
uh you may want to just somewhat down to
like five points I thought you even
write on the on the wall or put in a
piece of paper something like 5 q's or
something that you can cut in between to
say you know okay I'm telling Mike store
is why I'm doing it it could be like why
and you just have the wine then you look
at the camera so here's why I'm doing
right and then the next one just prompts
you um but practice is good face time is
good uh you know talk to your plant it's
good [ __ ] friend ok I'll have to
leave a plan first oh you don't have any
plans no I do I think just not in my
office ok
well whatever it helps to have an
audience even if it's at up for ten
d'audience yeah because you're looking
straight at the camera so it helps have
a focus point then just walking around
because it changes once once that lens
is on you and you sir have to sweat a
little bit and get nervous and yeah and
remember that if it sucks you don't have
to post like you can it's not live this
is live you mess up it's on YouTube may
be right but but you know the thing
you're doing you take as many takes as
you want if it sucks do it again if I
have to do it again if you wrote some
really powerful stuff so if you can get
like half of that out with energies it's
gonna begin yeah and you know for me I
was pretty surprised because writing for
for as long as I remember myself has
always been a painful thing I kind of
hated to do and would almost never do
and this thing just came out one shot I
just had to edit a couple spelling
mistakes and that's it liking it man I'm
like oh I guess it was sitting there
waiting its deep its deep within you
it's coming out I'm gonna so pop to see
this video man when's it coming out uh
you know what my goal is to get it out
within a week I just gotta practice it
nail it down you know make put it down
and make sure I'm happy with it that's
it so you haven't released any of the
fear interviews right no I haven't I I
haven't i've had a whole bunch of stuff
on hold but i've started editing a whole
bunch of stuff up cut some things that
other people need to approve so based on
something abuse of them some people they
have a right to approve it because of
the organizations are with ya so um but
most of that's already in process so i
will probably have a lot of juicy stuff
ready within a week good so are you
gonna lead with your like here's why I'm
doing it video yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
lead with that and I'm probably also
gonna have like a 30 second pic of me
before each HIV just kind of giving a
heads up of
who we're talking about and why was
important and maybe even teachable
lessons what what what was there to take
from that a you mean just ideas I'm
speechless man what happened this is
amazing yeah you know right now it's all
mine I'm liking and see the beach like
hay ride this wave while you're on it
bro that's awesome that's great yeah
like so you've done you got two videos
me and somebody else for fear yeah for
fear I have and I just basically I'm
including fear as a as a series of
questions in the success diary so
whoever the interview for its
accessories next I'll include tier into
it and whatever I could do a follow-up
interview I'll do follow-up interview
based on that okay perfect yeah so exam
connected series I like that and that's
experience on again you're gonna get on
before my video comes out you're gonna
do like a 30-second here's here's why I
want to talk to every here's what we're
going to talk about and then its income
into the interview I think so yeah yeah
man I'm loving it that's great yeah near
future I want to build it up figure
where I can it it's a bit more
production work for me but in terms of
maybe do like a one minute two minute
video on that person that I've we're
done interview with kind of showcasing
who they are their background or
accomplishments a little bit of a kind
of a trailer who that person is because
for most people watching it they don't
know who that most likely won't know who
the person that I'm interviewing is
where I be nice for them to kinda have
an understanding able to appreciate the
content even better one so they
basically so that the listening is
different when they're listening and
watching the interview what do you think
about that yeah I like it um you may be
able to use depends on who you're
talking to if they've done they may they
may already have footage to send you to
so like for me you could grab footage
from my
about me on stage at events me doing a
bunch of stuff right like you can rip
that and just put it into your intro so
you don't have to go film it right yeah
same thing for you know I don't know who
you're the people are you interviewing
if they have any kind of footage that
you can already use hey that saves a lot
of time instead of you having to go to
do it even if you take pictures they
have pictures of them doing something
you can you could talk to it or they
could talk to it and tell their story
maybe it's not the look you're looking
for but wouldn't cut down on your yeah
like if the guys part of his story is he
went to the Himalayans and he was there
for three months and rediscovered
himself you know you may not have video
footage of that but maybe there's some
awesome pictures he took of him in the
Himalayan so you could pop those up
there while he's telling that quick
intro story because you're not going to
go fly there with him back to the
Himalayas and take that footage man
unless he likes me I'm liking the
confidence man this is awesome um yeah
yeah this is what we've been talking
about this forever this is great yeah
yeah next week now I'd also so this is
an awesome track you're on I think in
addition maybe one like the buzz slows
down or whatever you know you you feel
the energy I love to still have some
photography video theory technique
philosophy in there because part of our
discussion is and the struggle that
you've had is how do i combine inspire
with my work with my business it's not
just about freed in this series but how
do I also then get more photography
clients you know into my company right
so it could be making a video to explain
your your philosophy of how you work
with clients the types of clients you
like working with as a kind of a lesson
for other people who are doing business
it could be how do you make people feel
at ease when they're in front of the
camera for the first time one of the
some of the things that because you're
really good at that you have me doing
like
superhuman your old stuff and football
poses and it's like naturally part of
your vibe but i think you know Louis
said it other people said it working
with you put somebody's and ends up
getting a great shot so um you know
incorporating that into the content that
you're creating and this will be a lot
easier once you're comfortable on camera
and you're starting to share more of
yourself talk about you approach your
philosophy the clients that you work
with projects that you like you inves
showcase and somebody else is doing a
great job talking about the pictures and
a project you're working on you posted
the one of them the dark story with the
light and the the gun right like
timeline about that right and saying why
you did it what your vision was behind
it it started with this light like
incorporate i love this ease those kinds
of videos too does that help the
business and it helps connect it to what
you're trying to do as a photographer in
addition to your films and your your
short stories and your documentaries and
your mashups and all that like it's all
all combined what would be a good first
one for you you think that kind of ties
to the company that isn't just like a
documentary or a short or a mashup
what's a good video that's a lute ly
easy start for you hmm good question oh
I need to put some thought in that maybe
maybe a part of the the process of how I
work with people and how I how it's
photographers more about your
interaction with the person in how the
space you create rather than just posing
them taking pictures so I'll think about
it a little bit more to see what more
will come 1st bubble feel right as the
first video but when I do create those
kinds of videos I think that's a great
idea you came up with how would I where
would I put it all would it still just
be in the same playlist I'm doing to
compartmentalize it some way or
look how well how does it make sense or
how where is it all sit so still sits on
your YouTube channel but you create a
different playlists for it so you got to
think about how you would think about
the themes so you're making one video
but it's not going to be standalone so
just like now you're creating success
Diaries that's its own series you're
creating sphere you have a name for
overcoming fear breaking fear you know I
don't I don't I don't have anything for
you okay well you're gonna you're gonna
have a name facing your fears I don't
know um and I'd like to see rhyme simple
like that oh just boys feared good here
whatever whatever works man you know so
and then under fear you're gonna have
all of these videos so the next series
that you do what's something that you
can talk about multiple times so if it's
going to be working with clients it's
going to be photography philosophy if
it's going to be you know shining the
light on other people's projects like
what's something you feel like you can
be more than just a one-off if you can
do what is a test so maybe your
interview with me for success Diaries
was a test and then you went out so now
that work so I'm gonna go and do more so
yeah well as a task but something that
you think has potential to do more and
then you may got the playlist so for
example could be if it's only going to
be about how it could be how to work how
to work in an inspired way okay inspired
work and and that could be all
encompassing of how you handle clients
how you set up the the room how you make
them feel comfortable and you could be a
video on each or could be more specific
it could be just about a series on how
to make somebody feel comfortable you
know how to have inspiring conversations
and the topic is inspired conversations
that's your playlist and then you come
up with videos on questions to ask and
setting the mood
and you know whatever like whatever you
do naturally yeah becomes its own video
and then you can share stories and
examples but figuring out where the
types of goodies you want to do and then
clumping them into a theme that becomes
your playlist and it's still inspired
its inspired conversations inspired
business inspired client work whatever
it is that becomes its own playlist it
still lives on you gotta love on your
YouTube channel on the website it could
be part of your your new website you're
having your you have chunks right yes
yes oh so for example the yeah I forget
the category you were reading and stuff
you have you have a video you had like
documentaries or interviews i think it
was so there you would put the interview
playlist the fear the success Diaries uh
then you have a section on photos and
celebrity so you can you can do a series
on working with celebrities what's your
approach to working with celebrities how
do you do it how do you make them feel
comfortable you know how do you work
with them what are the things hurdles
you have to go through what should I
learn from that that that video could be
on the celebrities page okay so on the
website it could be split up but on and
on your YouTube channel it's split into
different playlists okay but I love to
kind of tie that into your business
right so it's not just about the
documentaries in the short films or you
know interviews but you're you're tying
it into your photography business too
yeah and you know what have a feeling
this may even lead buca an evolution of
my photography video business might be
more focused in doing these kind of
interviews and this kind of content for
others cool yeah that'd be awesome if
you are regularly produced in this assay
and sorry if you are on if you are
regularly produced in that kind of
content you'll have people who will and
look
I lost is there oh you're losing your
connection there you go no I lost your
the volume for some reason um if your
regular using this kind of content and
doing great interviews and people will
who are looking to get interviewed and
increase their exposure will start to
come to you and say hey we need rich
yeah and then that should be on your
website right there should be a page on
your website that tells me that hey I
could hire you to come interview me and
give me a profile yeah and you know what
um i've just updated the website to the
chunks it's not online yet but i can
send you a preview to it you know what
you think I kind of broke it up into
photo portfolios video portfolios I
inspire my personal blog photo blog and
in the connect button like a connect
menu with me okay so ah I'll show you so
it makes sense and I guess in town we'll
figure out I'll figure out where I would
put the new content where where that
would fit there sure I'm progress yeah
hey you know what always is man it
always is my website is changing never
done it's never done always in evolution
good so what's new and exciting in Evans
world what's new and exciting Evans
world are we flipping in here is always
happening and we flipping the switch um
down in the mirror you're putting on
your you're interviewer hot here ah
what's new and exciting now i can't i
can't see you all right i can barely
hear you too so I'm just kind of trying
to figure out we've only got a few
minutes and i'm really curious to what's
going on with what you're doing and you
had talked before the doing some really
serious seem really cool interviews that
you were gonna go do yeah i'm doing so
i'm interviewing so that's for my book
i'm still work i'm trying to get a date
from jessica alba for march um I'm
trying to
do a family vacation in disneyland and
and my my older sister lives in florida
lives in California too I'm trying to
sync it up to go see Jessica and do the
Disney you see my sister and come back
but I haven't gotten a firm date her
filming schedule is just if she's not
filming she's promoting the film so it's
a it's hard but anyway press junkets
everywhere yeah ah tomorrow I have an
interview with a guy who runs a
technology company he he he said he
built his company off of one word
empathy and it's now worth two billion
dollars Wow I'm interviewing him live on
the channel tomorrow i want to say three
o'clock eastern not a hundred percent
but it'll be on the youtube channel um
and then a few others also some smaller
companies you know guys who who built
the 10 million or built two million or
you know things that may seem more
capable to people than a two billion
dollar company but i want to show that
you can use the strategy to help you
know a small business as well as build a
big business um honest company once from
zero to a billion in three years that's
huge growth uh this one I don't know how
long he's been around so I'll find out
I'll find out tomorrow on the call doing
another hangout yeah that's that's super
exciting I've got some fun projects on
you tube coming out that I'm really
excited about uh some secret kind of
ninja stuff that I'm working on that
some collaborations and some fun some
fun things that will be hitting soon um
just cross 25,000 subscribers on the
channel which is cool and three and a
half million views and still growing
like on track for for three and a half
four thousand new subscribers for the
month five hundred twenty-five thousand
total so it's like we're growing at over
ten percent every month which is
fun and awesome and chaotic still doing
two videos every day two videos
clockwork pump it out to be a little
more I did it I did an interview with
radio show earlier and then I had Jensen
for you and then you and then I have my
usual thank you thursday so before
videos hit the channel today but in
general we still got the two doing it
every day um yeah fun man working on the
book doing the videos yeah mother I
gotta take a plane your human Marvel
ought to know how you do so many things
at once well you interviewed me about
productivity yes do you not review the
book so your video is going up this week
once the next year one gonna be after
that um so is the next which fear one
yeah well your video is going to be on
the fear series right oh no no my video
is not on the fear series is just
basically the whole inspire series it's
on the whole success Diaries okay but
that's about and fear just part of it or
now I don't see it as a standalone just
a part of it both kind of a tangent well
I'm keeping my my eyes peeled on that
you gotta love YouTube channel man I'm
like new video comes out watch that I
gotta watch that rich on virus I'm going
at my screen but you can't see it if you
don't have the audio I can't see
anything except for my face there's a
lot of hand gestures head movements
exciting right yeah it's out of control
over here you gotta watch it on on your
end eat it maybe I need to interview on
how to use google hangout because I
haven't figured it out yet
yeah it's kind of tricky um yes I
thought it was simple there's just me
not spending any time with it uh well I
haven't had anybody not you know it
works on that phone but not on the
computer that's a little weird but I've
had people who haven't haven't gotten
invitation or you know they have to
install the software and so we're
delayed a little bit um so I'm thinking
of moving the Google live events which
I'm researching so if anybody watching
it has tips on Google live events
instead of hangouts let me know I'm
thinking about that for the next one
very cool sitting in I'm excited okay so
we're good then homework for next month
is basically creating these videos in
recap yeah so for next month i'd love to
see obviously that I mean the one you're
doing is already coming up right it's
coming up great you got momentum there
you don't need any anything else to
light your fire I love to see ideally
one publish but if not at least kind of
in the process of one related to your
business somehow okay you on camera
talking about something if it's a client
work a philosophy you have your butt but
like that helps me understand rich as a
photographer and here's how he brings
this to his business I love some thought
on that an ideally a video posted if you
want to email me you know some ideas in
between a month just for some feedback
happy to give that to you but I'd love
to see like at least two videos up one
your personal one and one you're
something related to your business ok
will do if you want to overachieve man
you go for it yeah see if I can ramp
myself up to you though you're in the
you're in the flow man you're in the
flow go for you want to do five videos
get those up I'm excited yeah i'll be i
need to drink some of the water you're
drinking I'm drinking pineapple Chi
excellent I've never i went to starbucks
i had two meetings is waiting at
starbucks back-to-back and i went i said
can I my vanilla rooibos
the word was anymore Oh thus which meant
they switch suppliers so so they
recommended pineapple kona pop that's
actually pretty good an interesting I
never heard of pineapple d but I'll
definitely give you trying well that's
what i'm drinking so also then all right
have a great right couple weeks rich
will talk to soon looking forward to
that video great thank you very much for
everything see your gears